Timothy Chalamet.
Timothy Chalamet? Timothy Chalamet. Timothy Chalamet. Why does that sound not as cool as TimothAE ShalamAE?
Hi guys, my name is Grace Helbig if you did not know, now you know.
Your life is different now! The SAG Awards happened over the weekend, that stands for Screen Actor's Guild,
not "Sorry Aunt Grace, you weren't invited again," awards. Fancy, beautiful people wore fabrics and other
elements of fashion, so let's review it! We're making quite the statement today, statement that we don't
want to be offensive, and also, we want dogs to feel comforted that they're seeing the exact
same color scheme of your fashions that humans are. I'm... so thoughtful. Let's jump right into these
SAG carpet fashions! Sad carpet...  Saggy carpet? That's a fashion statement. As always with these fashion
reviews there's a caveat that there was a ton of amazing actors at this award show
I will definitely not get all the people that you might want to talk about, so I'm sorry. Gina Rodriguez! Ahhh! You look
like you're wearing, like, a mosquito net that got just, like, full of nymphs and butterflies and you're just like
"No, time to shake it out! Let's wrap it around and here's our GAP Body
bra. CUTE! TimothAE ShalamAE. I don't care if that's not
how you say it, that's... how you say it. He looks like a young James Dean. I feel
weird, the feelings I have when I see Timothee Chalamet.
He looks so suave and young and hip and cool. He's so cool that he's like the kind of guy
that if you, like thought a cigarette was a candy cigarette and he just straight-up ate it, in front of you, you'd be like
That's a great idea. Also, I'm new and late, two thousand and late-teen, to TimothAE ShalamAE because I only just watched Call Me By Your
Name last night. I got so hopped up on this movie last night that I started doing all my research... AFTER I finished
checking up on all of Timothae Shalamae's social media profiles. I then looked at the film
which I found out is based on a 2007
novel called Call Me By Your Name and not only that, it is available in audiobook form, voiced by Armie Hammer
who if you don't know, plays Oliver in the film, which is love interest of Timothee Chalamet, no
spoilers. Which leads
me to, you guessed it, Audible! I team up with Audible all the time because I think they are a fantastic service.
Audible is offering all of you that are watching this video a free 30-day trial with
a free download. Go to audible.com/grace or, text "GRACE", G-R-A-C-E, to
500 - 500 and you can download a free title and start listening. And on top of that Audible
also has exclusives and original audio shows. I didn't know that. Like I said, I just downloaded Call
Me By Your Name
Name because I am SO curious to hear how it compares to the movie which I'm still processing, so throw all of
the Call Me By Your Name on top of me. The other cool thing about Audible, because if like
me which is like a dumb person. I have a hard time sometimes processing audio in real time. Audible now
has speed control so you can listen faster or slower or whatever pace makes the most sense to you. HOW
CONVENIENT IS THAT? So again, go sign up for your, free 30-day trial with a free download at
audible.com/grace. That's audible.com/G-R-A-
C-E or you can text "GRACE", G-R-A-C-E,  to 500-500
Side timothy chellamay has an effect on me i got i got a. Pump the brakes, millie bobbi brown
Sorry, i need, a moment to take a sec ah because you are every member of the spice girls
All-in-one and this is adorable, we had a little scary spice with the space buns, baby, spice with the baby
Pink, posh spice with the sequins subtle ginger spice with the cape
And some sporty spice with the converse sneakers look at
You, you've defied all fashion categories cute winona ryder
Also, from stranger thing and it's very much trying to tell us something she's sorry
About with her eyes did you shart did you shart it's okay, you still look really really pretty
Doing it one of the prettiest currently sharding, people i've ever seen
Cute sally, hawkins who's from shape of water which i also just saw
And guys i'm watching movies now
And it's taking a lot out of me it makes me tired this is very retro and cute and there's a lot
Happening this is like a magic, eye that points directly to your belly button or i look
Directly into the sun there like seventies fruit stripe gum it's, also a really great dress for people that
Don't want direct eye contact because i can't get, my, eyes up to your, face i've been i keep trying but
Still cute, halle berry this i dig i when do you, age you
Gonna give us a timeline on when you'd like to start aging, because that'd be great getting exhausting being so shocked at. How
Ageless you are but, also very inspiring this is very like, goth prom queen
Cute mary j blige oh, my, god i feel obliged to tell you that none of us can compete this is like
2018 swan lake or this like an episode of project runway theme, was like sesame street meets
Sex yeah reese witherspoon, this is so damn elegant god dang it you this color looks great on you you look
Like the princess of emerald city, who's here to say i've got clavicles yeah, yeah saoirse ronan
saoirse ronan
steer sure i'm
Seriously, sorry that i am not pronouncing, this correctly i know but look
Here you are what i meant to say?
pretty and demure and it ended up with pure which i guess isn't far off this looks nice on you this looks elegant and
High-fashion on me this would look, like just a diamond map of where i'm currently sweating under my dress cute kate hudson
Whoa, you look like
You're!
Baddest bitch at the country goth dance this is like
Westworld meets an avril lavigne music video and i don't hate it this is like, some queen and the victorian
Age had a daughter that loved paramore cute laura dern i love laura dern so much and gosh darn it you look
Gorgeous this is also a little victorian. Goffe but kind of modern and sexy
How dare you be able to pull off all of those descriptive things that i don't really even know
What i'm saying i'm just spouting a bunch of?
Kind of bullsh?
Stuff but i have been well-intentioned it's all well-intentioned you're lovely and you look, lovely
That was a journey cute got a girl, away she directed lady
Burdens getting a lot of critical acclaim i enjoyed that movie very much you look, like you know
Those candy strips that had the docks i'm gonna do like a you know
Punk, metal version of that candy and also you're not giving those foot fetish pervs what
They, want so get it girl cute nicole kidman
Always, looks goddang stunning congrats surprised, you did it again, this kind of looks like, you were born with
This, growth, where you have a bouquet of flowers coming out of your shoulder that you can't get removed and so you're like just
Put the dress over it no one will know
Cute allison janney da da stop but, also go give, me a
Future space football businesswoman
Oh, damn dead yes yes yeah
Someone just one adult prom in an episode of black mirror and i'm for it cute susan sarandon
I loved so much i saw that there, was some mixed reviews
About the sunglasses that she wore her but get it girl i heard that sun, was bright and would you rather over photo like
This or a folder like, this you're, susan sarandon you can, do it are the you, want wear flip up sunglasses, wear a hat
Wear some sunscreen on your nose you do you susan
Yeah, margot robbie i saw I, Tonya
and oh, my, god yeah i loved it so much. Highly
Highly recommend if you haven't seen it already but i do like, that this sorta is an ice-skating
Inspired outfit it's like, they took an ice skaters olympic outfit and then just added more gown to the bottom, also
Wouldn't it be funny if this is just how
We find out the margot robbie has some, weird earth disease where she grows, hair just in a singular
Strip around her upper abdomen, would really, humanize, her because she is pretty perfect
I know it's not true unless you, want to tell you something
No, yara shahidi i know i'm probably, saying that totally incorrect and i apologize but you look
Beautiful and you should apologize. You have made me insecure because you look so stunning, also when i looked at
This photo for a, while i thought you had some weird architectural side of your pantsuit that just went out
Like this and then i realize, that's just the arm on the wall behind you either way
Kristen Bell this is beautiful this color is so pretty you look, like a modern cinderella, or like a mom
That's like really showing up her daughter on one of those episodes of my, super sweet 16 tracee ellis ross ah
Cute! alison brie yeah you better brie-leave it you you, did it good sexy but
Also, still kind of feels 80s you look kind of like a second wife to a
Guy, who's like a lawyer and you walked into his law
Office christmas party for the first time and you were like i'm not here to make friends i'm here to make all of your wives
Extraordinary jealous his children will never love, me and i'm okay with that yeah allison williams this is beautiful you look
Like a chandelier you know the hourglass that shows up on PCs when the computer freezes
That but like a gatsby hourglass. Cute! natalie dyer, also from stranger things that
also, looks outstandingly
beautiful the top is this kind of like sheer netting and then the bottom looks like it has
Astrological signs all over that's super cool
She looks like the kind of girl, like sneaks her whiskey into homecoming in like a flask, that's made out of amethyst
Yeah, okay there you go guys there is my, sag red
Carpet fashion review i know i didn't get to a ton of people that you probably
wanna talk about so leave your favorites in the comments down
below. Don't forget to click subscribe to this youtube channel if you haven't already.
I make videos Tuesdays and Thursdays, for the time being. Other than that, I don't know.
No, how do you Timothee Chalamet? No, that's not what I wanted. But, also, am curious about. How do you pro-nounce
TimothAE ChalamAE